welcome to my talk um today i want to
talk about ai adoption in the enterprise
and five things
you should know about it uh and on
spoiler alert it's not
there's not only five things you will
need to know and just want to highlight
five of them
so uh yeah this is me you know i act
very active and my company is very
active in the in the community um i'm
also working on europe hyphen and i'm
a python software foundation fellow but
let's
tell me a little bit more what qualifies
me for this talk
in particular
um our motto at kunixvik is
transform to work smarter and i want to
tell you a little bit about what i
experience and some use cases i just
learned in the field
there are many
enterprises companies
moving into aci space or they plan to do
and um
and and usually we meet them when they
actually we should do something with ai
or we basically we started with ai on
our data science and we got stuck so can
you help this is basically how we meet
and how
these
cases i'm going to to to to present
are
come together so
i would really like to narrow it down to
five
key terms
strategy means skills culture and
patience these are like five terms you
need to know
about making things happen because it's
not just about technology
um there's many things
involved all around
making it happen
um so we won't go in this talk by term
by term so i'm going to
present you
some use cases stories stuff i've
learned out in the field and eventually
at the end of the talk you will see
where the strategy came in on the means
the skills the culture and we will
likely guess where we will require
patience
let me start with a story recently i met
an old friend at the train station
she was very excited because she just
changed jobs she was
she she she
was
being like she a chief digital officer
in in the company in the new company and
and yeah and
we met and they said how are you doing i
have this
new role i'm like super excited we i
know her really way back she's she's a
very competent and dedicated person and
i told her and she asked me what do you
do oh yeah i work in data ni and she
asked me oh great in my new role i have
to buy ai as well and then i was just
like where and i had like something like
this in my picture in my head how do you
do many people even like very um um
skilled people
no
imagining how can one be by ai in 2022
uh cut or piece yeah can you you know
how basically is the process of course
this was not
a technical person it was more like
management
communication
totally different domain and most of
we of us work in
so
what do we want to reach when we want to
step start with ai we want to be
productive we want extendable solutions
we want
insight decision making support
maybe even some wisdom
often it's unclear how to actually
launch
a project in a up and running
organization this is a very different
perspective we often perceive from
twitter or linkedin because there are
many great startups but it's i say it's
way easier to build like in a green
field and by build with the newest
technology or from scratch
then
establishing new technologies
in
a company which is has a business
already which has has a decent size
and also yeah has customers and a run up
and running business
so there are many
aspects to cover communication
a lot of communication there are many
stakeholders
ethics the value proposition resources
and also of course the engineering part
which is very often
a little bit underestimated if i want to
put it friendly
and also
depending on the
technical background and training of the
stakeholders
what is actually ai
so so let me refine the term ai
a little bit here for this talk so when
customers think of ai
they
very likely have a different picture
than
experts as
you and me
have in mind
for customers the term ai includes other
technologies very often like
robotic process automation it's
basically everything that's happening in
the digital space is a.i
and why is that so
because yeah the answer is pretty
obvious there are many suppliers and
anything digitalization you just have to
put some ai label on it because ai just
sells better so
we have many talks also some talks about
this here at this conferences or
conference before as well so basically
you don't need like the biggest ai tools
to solve the real problems but anyway
it's um so this is the this is the
perspective of the customer we need ai
we need to do something
without all the background we have
collected here in the room
so from that perspective the borders
between ai modern analytics often driven
by open source and the pi data ecosystem
are often like a little brewery and they
overlap with other technologies
so the perception
is actually all one needs is an idea
skills resources to make digitalization
nii happen
so why is everything taking so long once
people's like project started questions
come why is everything taking so long it
shouldn't be isn't that also easy i just
read this on twitter or linkedin
so shouldn't be you we all be finished
yesterday already so
the question is or how do we actually
start
very often ai is understood at a very
high level
but also what does i have an
understanding are
at high level of of ai actually means
many companies still struggle to find
the right starting point and
are we talking about information from
newspapers
on the executive level well because this
is very biased towards other
technologies
like gp3
and open ai okay there's robo writers
will take over the world and stuff like
that because that's newspaper stuff
but there's also a lot of ai happening
and being used on a daily basis i would
argue probably even the hourly basis you
just basically have to touch your phone
and
there will be something happening with
ai somewhere maybe or dictate a message
and
so it's very important at the beginning
to see what is actually understanding
and the expertise also in the team
what's the technical background of the
team
what is the level of experience and
practice do you already meet ai
practitioners in the team so and they
have started to educate others in the uh
and in the enterprise too
what is ai is about and what are like
obstacles and what are like um
the good parts
um
and
or and and also see what are the doubts
and biases in favor or against the new
technology
so you see there's a lot of fume and
stuff already involved just like by
defining what do we want to reach with
ai what is ai on an enterprise level
having like many many people in the um
involved also in the decision making
process and usually people in the
decision maker project they also have
the budget control they so they have to
agree okay we're going to move in ai and
this is going to cost us like
money
very often
another misperception is ai isn't just
like one ai
there are plenty of technologies um in
of ai systems that may or may not
interact with the gaja i think that's
pretty obvious to us here in the room
but
we cannot expect people who are not
actually practitioners in the field
know this already
a misperception is it's something you
just buy like software right it's code
it's data that sounds like software you
can just like buy off the shelf from a
supplier
and the question here is
is a one size fits all service
good enough to reach your goal will your
company need customers with a custom
solution to contribute extra value to
your
to your company
and of course there are many commodity
services nowadays already i mean there's
no need to train an own speak speech
recognition model for every single
company in the world
these are problems
where you can use a service but if you
you have to focus on what is basically
the core value and input of
the like domain knowledge of the the
company and how can ai help internally
or like externally
so as a specialist
market leakers in the domain will
require a custom ai solution that is not
available as a service
so as a first step at koenig's week we
identify what should we focus on first
does the company want ai to optimize
internal processes
is providing ai services on the roadmap
to clients or suppliers
and
also is
is there an end-to-end process
established already so is end to end at
least in the mind so basically you have
you start with your supplier and you end
with your customer and basically you
involve both in in your
end-to-end process um
and it's not just like okay you give it
here and then you basically throw it
over the fence and
go with it so the communication is also
an exchange of data and information is
all essential here
the first step is to establish a common
understanding with a client and see
if everything aligns and this sounds
like really simple oh let's sit and talk
and we do a workshop and everybody
hasn't everybody will love the workshop
and say yeah i totally got it it's
awesome and
i i can guarantee you it's not working
this way you meet like maybe
10 20 workshops yeah on specific topics
you have to be repetitive you have to to
to see
where there are also
misunderstandings because
many terms in information technology are
very blurry
it's sometimes even if i'm preparing for
a workshop sometimes oh i'm a little
tired let me
let me see
let me look up like a different
definition on wikipedia on some very
often you don't even find a clear
definition at all and if you find
definitions or if you refer to other
sources
you see okay the whole thing is quite
blurry and you really have to sit down
and say okay what is our understanding
here at this table
for this technology what you should
solve or not and
and when how everything around fits in
so this brings me
to my favorite next case uh
there is an ai prototype in place
already these are my favorites so
the company
very likely so there's a working student
and
he just he's doing probably like a
master's in data science and he comes in
into a company
and says okay i have this idea i learned
stuff in in
at university and
we could do data science and and on an
ai project and we said okay cool we're
working student we don't need much
budget for this let's do this um so the
working student
pitches
pitches a project hey i have this great
idea
what about this i built a little
prototype and shows it to stakeholders
all around in the company and of course
the stakeholders are just accepting oh
we never thought this is like so easy to
do ai and data science this is this is
just like awesome yeah
so the prototype is not actually
perceived this is just like a prototype
and or a proof that something is working
on a single machine and it's just like
um based on open source and blog posts
and very helpful people who i love the
stuff is put online but it doesn't
really solve specific problems in
companies so
what happens here so everybody's just
like
super excited hey this is awesome and of
course if people are excited and
and see something is working
we do not lack of ideas
so
stakeholders
there's an
exchange likely the driver of the
project is also regularly excited i have
this idea i want to add this i want to
add this we should do this we should
that and this really usually very well
resonates with everyone involved and
more more and more ideas come into the
project and more and more requirements
come into the project and
this is the next what happens then now
there are so many ideas in the project
because there's only
a single person or very few people
driving it and
at the end of the day
you have to just realize that um
there's a lot of motivation and ideas
and i love that
and there's usually only some
programming skills involved
and also of course there's a belief in
hypes there
and this all is mixed with actually a
lack of experience bringing stuff to
production
in an ecosystem
which is up and running already it's not
hey i can do data in ai and please adapt
the rest of the enterprise to my jupyter
notebook
i guarantee you it's the other way
around
and there is a lack of software
engineering usually you lack like so
everything you need for production like
unit tests yeah you need to be stable
it's uh
there's like inventive parks like being
like but it works in my notebook um
and
so like very often
because you also need experience how
does everything fit in into the existing
and future
architecture of
the company
and very often there's also a lack of
methodology so how do you manage a
project like this in an orderly fashion
because it's not just like one person
making all the calls picking up ideas
liked or not um
so
yeah there's uh this is like basically
the menu of the day
like yeah you get spaghetti code and
this is a colleague of mine draw this
through this uh this is how people feel
when they after they like review the
project from a technical production
ready perspective this is what they draw
and i said wow
so the best practice here is
to
have good ideas try things out i mean
it's great how fast we can do like proof
of concepts and prototypes nowadays um
but know when to stop to develop further
like find allies and resources to
to make it into a real project and also
involve stakeholders and be really
patient over the stakeholders explaining
this be patient with everybody on the
team to
to to establish the processes because
you have to retune processes
methodologies from time to time until
it's read until it's really ready um
and
be transparent about it and
involve everyone
needed
so
lighthouses if you build like a lot of
these height houses you don't have a
strategy you just have a bunch of new
silos so the question here is
do you have a strategy or just a bunch
of ideas so and this brings us to the
next topic legacy and burdens because
likely big parts of your enterprise are
running on legacy systems
running for
10 20 30 40 i think the maximum i've
learned for 60 years which was also
impressive in a way
new services need to act interact with
the legacy systems most often for
accessing data
and it sounds easy right but the legacy
systems in place are not meant
they might not meet the requirements of
modern ai
services
there's also a personal shortage in
basically anything ai so people
responsible for running the legacy
systems are very busy and also hard to
get and especially how to get okay we
have these new requirements we need we
need to sit together we want to explain
what we need so
we also have to bring everybody on board
to have the the right understanding what
we want to accomplish and what our is
what is everybody's eq requirements are
um so
we need time to talk and understand each
other and
and of course but i think most of you
know that already the biggest problem is
also access because there is
a lot of different systems and over time
you basically have like a an axis
labyrinth nobody really knows who has
access firewalls and and all this so
it's also not easy and it might be time
be time intensive to think who has
access who can actually agree you hack
your team gets access um
so and this is also something
you need to know you need to also be
able to work
with
people working with legacy systems you
have to understand their obstacles how
they work how they think also what their
what their needs are um you need to
understand also their pain so basically
to to get together okay how can we solve
this together and this brings me to the
next it's also company culture so the
question is is a company culture like
this established already
and
are the hierarchies flat or is it just
on paper are we just in transition
um did we have a good start making
change happen and making company culture
evolve into flat hierarchies and
everything or
also
another open questions
we after a great start are we falling
back into old routines because
we are humans humans are
routine
people so everybody likes routines so so
it's even it's not even like people do
this on purpose um there yeah we
interact with other humans and basically
we have routines and this change is hard
and changes takes time and you have to
be patient
innovation
is
complex so i think with the lighthouse
project i gave you like a good use case
we see
who you have to involve that it's not
easy um i think um if you're a
prediction practitioner this is you know
that already but i think one of my main
takeaways here is it's a complex project
you have to prepare for this and if you
are just like say okay i'm only i i like
to program you need somebody on your
side that can help you to get around
like talk to other people have a common
understanding so it's this is also not a
task a single person can do
basically it's also you need a great
team um
where you can
work together because this is like this
is just like not even covering all
departments this is just like covering
one department and how management
apartments development and operations
interact and of course you also have to
see
be
remember they're like simple things
people are on holiday so not everybody's
available all the time and maybe you
have to wait three weeks for a decision
or input from this that person
so you really have to prepare
to manage and juggle
like at least five balls
uh keep like five balls in the air at
the same time or be part of a team which
is capable doing that so there is
there's multiple roles involved as well
like more or less technically
management
scrum stuff so yeah so but it's very
important you this is functional to make
extra and to make ai really happen in
the company
so
if you like complex problems like this
and
if you like to be a data engineer or a
back-end programmer yeah so we are also
hiring
um just get in touch talk to me talk to
my my my partner zero or
my colleagues at our booth downstairs
and if this sounds fun um i i like
challenges nah like challenges like
organize organizing conferences
volunteers so but
yeah just get in touch and
that's i think the end of my talk
thank you very much
thank you so much
thank you so much alex um so there's
actually a few questions online
available so if you're happy to answer
them um of course then i would try to
pick a few of them so um have you ever
honestly seen a ds team with uh bigger
than one roi i mean it seems to me that
all teams have below one actually and
require massive infrastructure
investment
i'm not quite sure what is roi but
return of investment but it's quite
complex i think
actually i think this is a little bit
too generic to answer maybe i can get
the full answer but usually once it's in
production it's really hard to measure
it depends of course it depends on the
use case so if you say we optimize a
certain service and we can are also able
to track
the the the return of investment we do
here are or like the benefit we bring to
the company um yes but very often
these services just like disappear
somewhere in the ecosystem at extra
value and
also
usually we just lack
the the technology and services actually
monitoring stuff like that but that's
also i think it's actually a really good
question and we should monitor return of
investment better so
yeah yeah very good so our next question
is uh given how much understanding of ai
and trust you need in the company uh do
you think that consultancy can provide
valuable ai
for example
you know someone i think that this uh
author of the question asked because
they used to be working in the similar
situation yeah um okay there's there are
many consultancies so i can only speak
for ko next week i can guarantee you yes
we can
and
no because it's also really important of
course to come to an understanding and
something i haven't covered extensively
here uh is ethics we also need to
discuss with the client's ethics data
protection uh we have to discuss
data and and everything around it um so
yeah but of course i it's
i let me phrase it like that it's i
happened to come to clients who did
stuff before where there were not so
satisfied very it was basically just
like really high level stuff copied
slides
and not not content so for us it's not
we don't do when we sit together with
the client we don't okay we have some
slides to support but basically main
stuff is communication what's the goal
at the value is everybody bored and and
and and then also think
which which are the technical
requirements um roadmaps and stuff of
course a lot of stuff it's just like
i've seen presentation oh ai an
innovation
cloud
so on and yeah it's like it's a broad
market so
there's always like good people and
others
yeah so um one more question uh what do
you see as the relative uh pros and cons
of trying to do a ai innovation with an
internal startup versus uh through
existing team and organizational
topology oh wow that's a really good
question um
[Music]
i mean there's always like a team who
has to to keep everything running so i
think
my favorite solution would always be
okay there are people in place let's get
everybody on board educate and
train in new technologies because the
best thing that can happen is you have
people in the team who know the legacy
systems and know the new stuff and know
how to basically connect everything and
make things work together
unfortunately i also happen to be in a
project where it just didn't work also
because as i mentioned earlier there are
everybody's very busy
and to learn new
technologies you need time and if
time if you lack of time and you cannot
just like learn python in two hours if
you come from another language and it's
just not a side project
so i would say
the first one is still my favorite
because i think it's great to involve
with people with all the moments just go
further because they know
so many more things from their domain so
i think that's that's still the best but
i wouldn't also not argue against
building a startup although i think
we're only the startup within a company
has other obstacles because you're not
connected
to the people with the domain knowledge
and
you don't really know who to call you
has to i mean you have the new
technology of the green field
but basically you might lack
hey
what what how does it actually work how
did we use to do this all over time or
what do we have even in place so so so
yeah this is my
these are my thoughts on this question
yeah i think that's the time for the
questions and thank you so much alex and
now we're thank you so much for coming
on stage in a few minutes thanks for
joining thank you for joining on um
yeah thank you so much